bienvenidos sean de nuevo vamos a ver el
problema 15 y bueno tal vez esto del s
te parezca algo cansado y sé que
seguramente pusiste los ojos en blanco
cuando dije esa frase porque tú eres el
que tienes que tomarlo no yo pero de
cualquier manera problema 15 la gráfica
siguiente y eso está en la página 399
muestra la altura de la línea en
pulgadas así que vamos a hacer la
gráfica que tengo aquí en mi libro vamos
a dibujar aquí dos ejes este va a ser un
primer eje aquí va a ser mi segundo eje
muy bien y lo que vamos a comparar es la
edad la edad del inah a comparación de
su estatura entonces aquí vamos a poner
a su altura y ahora lo que nos da esta
gráfica son varios puntos según la edad
nos da una edad de seis años una edad
ocho años una edad de diez años y una
edad de doce años mientras que por otra
parte tenemos su altura y dice que
cuando tenía seis años su altura en
pulgadas era 45 pulgadas así que los voy
a poner aquí 45 pulgadas cuando tenía 6
años cuando tenía 8 dice que tenía 50
pulgadas así que vamos a tener por aquí
el 50 y entonces vamos a poner un punto
cerca de este lugar muy bien cuando
tenía 10 años tenía 50 y casi 55 así que
si por aquí tenemos 55 pulgadas entonces
esa línea tiene una altura casi de 55
así que lo voy a poner como por aquí muy
bien y cuando tiene 12 años alcanza las
60 pulgadas entonces 60 pulgadas
más o menos es como por aquí muy bien y
después unen todos los puntos con una
recta entonces vamos a ponerle que la
altura está en pulgadas y la edad está
en años
entonces juntan todos los puntos y se ve
algo así tal vez esta no sea la mejor
recta pero más o menos así lo ponen en
el libro y bueno nos preguntan en qué
porcentaje es mayor la altura de alina a
la edad de 12 años a comparación de la
altura que tenía a la edad de 6 años y
para esto vamos a ponerlo aquí en la
tabla la edad
la edad a comparación de la altura y las
edades que quiero comparar es la edad de
12 años a comparación de la edad de 6
años y al inah tenía una altura a los 12
años de 60 pulgadas tiene una altura de
60 pulgadas mientras que a los 6 años
tiene una altura de 45 pulgadas y bueno
no se preguntan qué porcentaje qué
porcentaje es mayor de altura del inah a
la edad de 12 años a comparación de la
altura que tenía a la edad de 6 años es
decir lo que no están diciendo es 60 en
qué porcentaje es mayor que 45 y bueno
curiosamente es algo que hago
cotidianamente en mi trabajo yo me
dedico a los fondos de inversión y bueno
esto de una manera rápida se resuelve
así lo que hay que hacer es dividir 60
que es la altura que tenía al inah a los
12 años entre 45 que es la altura que
tiene la línea a los 6 años
a lo que me estoy refiriendo es que
cuando yo divido 60 entre 45 estoy
diciendo cuántas veces cabe 45 en 60 o
dicho de otra manera lo que estoy
diciendo es 60 qué porcentaje es de 45 y
bueno si yo a 60 lo divido entre 45 y
dividiendo entre 15 tanto arriba como
abajo me va a quedar cuatro tercios
cuatro tercios y cuatro tercios es lo
mismo que 1.33 333 o 1.33 periódico y
bueno justo lo que estoy diciendo en
este momento es que 60 si los verdes de
la otra manera es el 133 por ciento o
bueno 133.333 tres periódicos por ciento
de 45 y fíjate lo podemos pensar de esta
manera si 60 es el 133 por ciento de 45
y lo que nos preguntan es en qué
porcentaje es mayor en qué porcentaje
mayor la altura de alina a la edad de 12
años a comparación de la altura que
tenía a los 6 años yo lo que quiero
saber no es qué porcentaje es 60 de 45
yo lo que quiero saber es en qué
porcentaje es mayor y si 60 es el 133
por ciento de 45 la otra forma de verlo
sería decir que 60 es 33 por ciento más
grande 33 por ciento más grande que 45
porque además de hacer el 100 por ciento
de 45 hay que aumentarlo un 33 por
ciento 45 para que me dé 60 y espero no
te esté confundiendo mucho tal vez lo
podría ver de la siguiente manera 133
por ciento
pues 33 por ciento más grande por ciento
más grande que un 100 por ciento estás
de acuerdo así que ya está la respuesta
de este problema es que 60 es 33 por
ciento más grande que 45 o dicho de otra
manera la altura que tenía al inah los
12 años es 33 por ciento más grande que
la altura que tiene al inah al 26 años
que por cierto es el inciso c así que lo
voy a atrapar aquí y vamos a borrar este
pizarrón para hacer otro problema más en
el tiempo que nos queda así que volvemos
el pizarrón y vamos a hacer el problema
16 el problema dice así tenemos un
cilindro así que déjame intentar dibujar
por aquí a mis lindroos recuerda que
estoy haciendo esto en vivo así que tal
vez no me quede el mejor cilindro que
has visto en toda tu vida
vamos a intentar hacer un cilindro es
quien me gusta así que vamos a hacer
otro cilindro por acá vamos a dibujar de
sus lados entonces este va a ser uno de
sus lados este va a ser otro esos lados
y bueno esencialmente este cilindro nos
dicen que tiene de base un radio de
equis y además tiene una altura y déjame
poner esto con otro color tiene una
altura de 2 x así que vamos a dibujar
aquí su altura y nos preguntan cuál de
los siguientes volúmenes es equivalente
al volumen del cilindro y me dan cuatro
incisos con un bonche de volúmenes así
que creo que lo mejor que podríamos ser
primero es sacar el volumen de este
cilindro y bueno esencialmente sacar el
volumen de un cilindro es equivalente a
pensar en sacar el volumen de un círculo
y multiplicarlo por la altura y bueno lo
que hay que recordar es como sacamos el
área de un círculo el área de la base y
el área de la base esencialmente es lo
mismo que pin por el radio al cuadrado
pero el radio es x por lo tanto sería pi
por x al cuadrado
y si yo lo que quiero sacar es el
volumen de este cilindro pues el volumen
es igual al área de la base por la
altura pero la altura es 2x entonces a
esto lo voy a multiplicar por dos equis
y bueno el volumen de este cilindro que
tengo aquí va a ser igual a pi por equis
cuadrada por 2x lo cual es dos veces pi
por equis elevado al cubo lo que tengo
que hacer es encontrar entre estas
opciones que te voy a dar un volumen que
sea igual a 2 por x al cubo y bueno el
inciso am nos dice que este volumen es
equivalente al volumen de un cilindro
que tenga como radio 2x y como altura x
entonces vamos a ponerle como altura x
pues vamos a ver si recuerda que este es
el radio y esta es la altura entonces el
volumen de un cilindro se saca como el
área de la base que es
por el radio pero el radio vale 2x
elevado al cuadrado por la altura que es
x y si te das cuenta este volumen me
sale por 4 x al cuadrado por x lo que es
lo mismo cuatro veces pi por x al cubo y
aquí ya tengo un problema esta no sería
mi respuesta correcta porque tenemos un
volumen de 2 px al cubo y no un volumen
de 4 pies al cubo así que vamos a ver
qué me dice el inciso b me dice que
tengamos un radio de 2 x de 2 y x y una
altura de x y bueno esto suena muy muy
raro porque nuestro volumen quién sería
sería pi por el radio elevado al
cuadrado por dos pi x todo esto elevado
al cuadrado por la altura y aquí de una
manera muy rápida se nota que esta no es
mi respuesta correcta porque aquí me va
a salir 2
equis elevado al cuadrado lo cual va a
ser 4 cuadrado x cuadrado y aquí no
tenemos nada que ver con pi cuadrada
entonces el inciso b tampoco es y vamos
a ver el inciso c el inciso se me dice
que el volumen de este cilindro es
equivalente al volumen de un cubo cuya
arista vale 2x y bueno si recordamos
cómo sacar el volumen de un cubo pues el
volumen de un cubo es la arista o el
lado elevado al cubo sería 2x elevado al
cubo lo cual es 2 por 2 por 2 es 8 x por
x x x men x cúbica entonces el volumen
de este cubo es 8 x cúbica que no es 2
px cúbica y por lo tanto esta respuesta
tampoco es así que vamos a ver qué es lo
que me dice el inciso de el inciso de me
dice y tenemos aquí una figura
geométrica es
una caja o más bien dicho un prisma
rectangular y déjame dibujarlo por aquí
más o menos se ve algo así más o menos
así y tal vez no me quedó la mejor caja
del mundo pero esta caja tiene como
largo 2 x tiene como ancho x y tiene
como altura pi x el volumen de esta caja
que tengo aquí quién es su volumen es
largo por ancho por altura es decir 2 x
que va a multiplicar a x que a su vez me
multiplicar a pi por equis y si nosotros
calculamos este volumen el volumen va a
ser igual a 2 por fin es 2 pin y después
x x x por x es x elevado al cubo que es
justo el volumen que teníamos aquí
arriba de este cilindro de lujo pues es
justo lo que queríamos un volumen de 2
px al cubo lo cual me da la respuesta el
inciso de enhorabuena
tenemos esta respuesta y por lo tanto
aquí voy a acabar este vídeo